just a couple weeks ago tweet came out
oh my God they're going to be free today
oh this thing's a every day someone's
saying they're going to be free today
they're going to be free today with
where you are today what is your level
of optimism of how this thing's going to
end
I have a great deal of optimism in where
this will end as far as what's currently
being investigated because again there
have been what's really important and
all this time that's passed there has
been no new evidence no new alleged
victims nothing new to support this case
and clearly at this point the evidence
has not been strong enough for them to
file charges against the brothers so I
think they're going to push this
preventative arrest you know because
they can for now while they're looking
for evidence but
everything I've seen I think it is not
going to be hard to disprove all of
these uh allegations so I'm I'm very
optimistic in the ultimate result of
this case obviously it's not as soon as
we would like we
um each day they're in custody we feel
like it's an injustice because they
should be home but the only other thing
I want to add is that
you know you hear human trafficking and
that sounds awful but this is
this is just not a case of human
trafficking and again without getting
into the evidence obviously it's
difficult to explain really what I mean
but this you know to emphasize the
webcam business is a legitimate business
in Romania many women have come forward
there's articles you can read about how
about why this is such a thriving
business there and this gives women
there a means of making a lot more
income
um you know some of the time women don't
have the means or the education to make
the kind of money that they could get
from an industry like this and you know
their standard like any other job they
have set hours they they you know take
royalties they pay commissions to the
business that they're dealing with so
this is not
um something unusual in Romania it
really is a legitimate thriving business
and they are trying to take this
legitimate business and criminalize it
in this particular scenario and I think
it's going to ultimately fail
well that you just that's a Playbook you
know that's the The Playbook is hey if
we uh uh just this question on what you
just said right the Curiosity so if it
wasn't illegitimate and it wasn't a
crime to go to jail can the government
suddenly create a law and get it passed
to be in then to get someone where
you're convicting them of a crime
because the laws have changed today
because that's what Giuliani did with
the mop and all of a sudden 240
something people went to jail on the
same day can they do that or that's not
something they can do
quickly you can't enact I mean you could
enact legislation but it's on a moving
forward basis there's no in a criminal
context there typically is no
retroactive application so if something
had you know predated when the Law
changes then you can't go back and say
something you did because you know for a
criminal charge you need to have noticed
that the behavior is deemed to be
criminal conduct so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
foreign